I'm empathetic to Leon's point of view
here I think that there's a
misunderstanding of what we're speaking
about here I'm not looking for people to
be indecisive or lazy or passive or not
urgent on the opportunity
I think is absolutely right start now
move fast don't settle absolutely my
whole thing is a little bit more what
happened
saying that if you have it and you're 32
28 41 49 that you should start now move
fast and don't settle too many people
get into a dwelling mindset a woe is me
[__] I missed it to me start now move
fast don't settle is 6 16 26 36 46 56 76
don't get it twisted
about passiveness this is about loving
yourself and not beating yourself up for
what you've done wrong in the past